how's it going how's it going I'm back
what do you mean you didn't know I was
gone oh I'm back I've been on holiday
but I also been sick it's been a lot of
fun so much fun
loved every second of it I haven't
missed this [ __ ] at least that's what
I said Oh Edgar Froese it's so great to
be back with you and make videos since
it's almost Christmas I feel like now is
the perfect time to go out and spend
time with your family and friends and
who does that [ __ ] let's be honest here
we're gonna do another playthrough a
Christmas play throw so it's time for
you bros to vote again I selected three
games you bros get to vote which one you
want to see us play first one is course
party the second one book of shadows
second one is [ __ ] I forgot
second one is murdered soul suspect
third one is call of duty I'm sorry
third one is Hello Kitty roller escape
to vote just click any of these it will
open a new window and the video with
most likes it's the one that's the
winner so you can go to all of them and
like or dislike good but yeah I'm
excited to start now to play through
with your brows I think it'll be a lot
of fun it's been way too long let's be
honest and I feel like playthroughs are
really when we are the closest cuz this
is usually just unedited and bro action
please don't call child services I don't
know what I'll do without him
but yeah Shiva good happy Christmas
thing and I'll see you inside the the
video all right cool
excited brothers get pumped as a
breakfast for you as always stay awesome
bread